what's up everyone how you doing today
today's video will be the final chapter
of the plot lake discussion that I had
with the dawn of Ice and Fire
there were a few audio glitches in the
remaining episodes so I condensed the
rest of the conversation that way the
audio sounds pretty good and everything
in this video is the biggest scenes that
we're left to talk about from the plot
leaked so I hope you enjoy this the main
focus is on the season 7 finale and the
dragon pit scene and if this is true
then this should be some of next
season's biggest scenes so let's get
right into it
the next part of this plot leak has been
one of the more controversial parts from
the leak that has stirred up some heated
debates this part is when Songza
sentences Littlefinger to death which
arya carries out sometime earlier in the
season Littlefinger attempted to pit
Arya and Sansa against each other by
using an old letter saunter wrote under
duress by the Lannisters to Robb Stark
but brand helps Sansa see through little
fingers ploy okay um here's the thing so
it sounds like [ __ ] to me yep uh you
know look I could see the whole thing of
Littlefinger trying to get fossa and
Sansa and Arya to be at odds somehow but
I mean like for one
what does Littlefinger still doing in
the North Littlefinger should be off to
the Vale especially once John has
decided he's going to go to Dragonstone
he should be off to the Vale and be like
look John left you in charge you know
you don't need the Knights of the Vale
here and you know he sense since you're
still acquiescing them running things
you come see me when you actually want
to be queen but let's say for the sake
of argument that he decides to stay in
the north for whatever Littlefinger
reason
Sansa needs to have a reason to execute
Littlefinger beyond
oh you gay
leave her you know you gave are you a
letter that I wrote to rob asking him to
lay down his crown and come to swear
fealty to Joffrey
but who got to be coming way bigger than
that
yeah because little thinker has already
done way worse [ __ ] than that exactly so
look you know what I personally think is
in a wound up happening is that
somewhere along this journey Arya and
the Hound are going to meet up and Arya
is going to tell the Hound that Sansa is
hanging out with Littlefinger little
sweet the Hound is going to tell Aria
like hey well you know your sister
really shouldn't be hanging around that
guy because he's the one that betrayed
your father in the throne room I could
absolutely see that now you know it
could be a thing where are your wives
are telling Sansa you know right then
and there but I I think that for one
little finger needs to die in Vale you
need to be pushed out the moon door
sweet Robyn needs to know about what
happened to his mother because of
Littlefinger and it's got to be because
of the fact that Sansa found out about
what happened in the throne room and
Littlefinger killed both of sweet
Robyn's parents technically surely the
one thing that doesn't make sense to me
about this is according to this plot
leak it basically says little finger
stays at Winterfell for the entire
season and that just doesn't sound right
right it makes no sense the war is over
you know why are the Knights of the Vale
still in the north they've done their
job they got to go back to the bill now
yeah I could see him hanging around for
a little bit when Jon initially leaves
to try to like turn her some more but
like you said if if she's standing her
ground and he's going to want to
leave Winterfell and make some other
moves somewhere else right so I mean
again like I said you know as
Littlefinger is going to die you know if
if you're going to do it right they got
to use all of the foreshadowing that
they've done they got to use everything
that Littlefinger himself has has done
and turn it back on and they can't just
be oh and pissed off fetching
Littlefinger you know now you die Arya
we do be honest or of killing Petyr
Baelish which like to know they have to
have a reason got to be you know
something substantial can't just be oh
you how dare you show arya this letter
that I wrote asking Rob's and give up
being king in the north
yeah I agree songs and others little
thinker has done like so many more
things than that so you're going to
decide to kill him over that like why
wouldn't you have sentenced him to death
or even had bran kill him in moles town
when he's done so many things that were
much worse than that
yeah so that's the only the only way I
could see the little finger dyeing any
anything else or any other any other way
that he dies if it's not being pushed
out the moon door and sweet robin saying
you know make the bad man fly I'm going
to call [ __ ] on it I'd be fantastic
I hope to god he goes to that moon door
make the bad man fly yes sir
now this next part I'm curious to see
what you think about this it says Cersei
wakes up in a bed soaked with blood
presumably from a miscarriage at some
point earlier in the season there is a
plot thread where Cersei finds out she
is pregnant with Jaime's child some
people have been speculating that maybe
it's your own child um well for one that
would be super interesting if it was
Euron's kid
ah that would be beyond interesting
because bright yeah because like what
kind of interplay do Cersei and Jaime
have after that yes you know you're on
is gonna be the duel is saying yes I
[ __ ] I [ __ ] the first clean of
Westeros again I can't see Jaime just
standing there as you're on you know
tries to take his place and push him to
the side Jaime is not going to allow
that to happen yeah so um I don't think
it's going to be Euron's kid but that
would be so so interesting if it was but
um yeah you know what what Jaime and
Cersei don't need to have any more kids
and Plus also that would go against
Maggie Fox prophecy anyway so you know
she's only supposed to have three kids
so technically she only had three kids
yeah do you think they're actually going
to do this next season and show a scene
like that I could see it happening I
mean remember you know when she's
talking to something you know uh she
tells her that she likes [ __ ] her
brother cuz it makes her feel good to
have him inside her so you know when you
do enough of that eventually somebody is
pregnant absolutely right we could see
that this next part it says salmon brand
somehow figure out Jon's parentage that
he is the son of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen his real name is Aegon
and he was legitimized at Birth not a
bastard again how how how not that I
can't see any of it happening but
because we don't have enough details I
need to know how I can't just accept
this long strange value I can accept
that it is possible that all of these
things work
true but without hearing the how I can't
fully embrace it and champion it yeah
how do you think they would figure this
out I'm assuming they would both be at
Winterfell at this point since Sam left
Old Town in Episode five and he said
bran arrived in episode three or four so
I'm assuming they would figure this out
at Winterfell if this is true so if this
did happen like this how would they have
done it something in the crypts
is he out in the godswood at the
weirwood tree like you know I wonder how
they would do this right because is it
going to be able for him like are they
going to be able to show a show Sam what
brand saw you know and then let's let's
look at some other things here right so
how was he with Jin Mazda birth and
Rhaegar already had a son named Aegon
right so you know for those of you who I
don't know should I even talk about a
dance with dragons upper training for
what pertaining to Aegon sure you want
you know what no because some people out
there who haven't read the books it's
not going to be relevant to them I don't
want to spoil for people who might
actually read the books well let's just
put it like this if you look at the show
it talks about how the mountain and
Amory Lorch killed regulars to kids and
his wife the boy that he killed was
named Aegon and so how in the world
would Rhaegar have two sons both with
the same name yeah I'm not sure why he
would do that
yeah so um you know again I have a hard
time believing I mean even for all of
Dan and Dave's faults I have a hard time
believing that they would just try to
throw that in there like no one is
supposed to notice right
ask you this too at this point does
brand even need Sam to help him figure
out John's parents we'll see here's the
thing right he seems that there's a baby
born right he knows that lianna now had
a kid he knows that's about all he knows
right he is going to be you know because
think about it like this if you are in
brands position like like okay there's a
baby that was born to the tower joy I
mean yeah I guess he could figure out
that it was John I mean the baby was
born with black hair and he he now knows
that that's the baby his father brought
home from the war to like he knows he
knows John was brought home right from
Ned so now he knows that that baby
actually came from Lyanna right so I
mean but still how would he figured out
the whole legitimized at birth thing no
I don't mean legitimized but the scene
he even needs to himself just to know
who John's parents are oh no he wouldn't
he wouldn't need Sam's help for that one
but again it's still the whole thing is
if John is supposed to be claimed by the
Targaryen then we have to know how it
was he would have been legitimized birth
yeah I'm guessing in this part I'm
assuming that they mean Sam must have
found something at the Citadel I don't
know while bran would need Sam unless
they went to the crypts and found
something either way I mean that's gonna
I mean like talk about high hurdles to
leap because that one I don't know how
you'd explain that one I just um I can't
wrap my brain around a logical
explanation for how John is legitimized
at Birth I'm guessing are meaning that
Sam must find some type of certificate I
don't know why
else they would say Sam helps brain
figure it out I'm assuming that means
Brandt or Sam must have found something
yeah it's just what yeah exactly exactly
if John was supposed to be in hiding all
this time it's something that would have
been kept
you know tucked away somewhere and
that's part of the reason why you know
no one really mentioned it it was like
okay we need to put this whole thing to
bed but the maesters was going to keep
records because that's what maesters do
so I mean I can see it just being a
thing where they decided okay look we
need the yeah we have this record
already but since there is no way of
really checking on this Roberts is the
king now we're just going to you know
put this in this book and that's just
where it's going to stay and if anything
sandwiches
stubble on it by accident it wouldn't be
a thing where it's not something he's
actively looking for but it just seemed
like something that would be of interest
because maybe it's like oh I never heard
about this talki Aryan kid who is this
yeah I always kind of pictured it like
if they were going to do it like that we
know how big the library is so I think
if they were going to explain it they
could just act like it's one of those
books that was like tucked away
somewhere that no one has seen since it
was put there read so I mean I think
that's I think that's one that's the
thing that's going to wind up happening
that's going to be interesting to see
how they do that right and I do want to
talk about a bother John's parents in a
second um do we have anything else as
far as this particular episode is
concerned yeah it says John and Danny
have sex on a boat uh I mean okay I
could see it happening just for
fanservice if that would be the only
reason I think yeah yeah because I mean
for one you know
they're in the middle of war what do
they need to have sex for like what is
the purpose
yeah Alma's just nearly killed exactly
so yeah that's gonna be a big moment if
they do that I mean like said is
fanservice II as hell yep absolutely
no like other than that it like it does
not it does not move the food the story
forward whatsoever do you want to see it
like not because you think Danny sexy
but do you just want to see these two
characters have sex
oh I mean now knowing you know now
having it confirmed that uh that John is
Daenerys is nephew not really that's how
I always felt about this I said I do not
want to see that nor like Walt or Gary
ins have always done this and I said I
know and they're like well incest has
already been introduced to the show it's
not that big of a deal and I'm like I
understand all that but I just still
don't like it
yeah you know who you know forgive us
for our squeamish sensibilities when it
comes to that stuff wet yeah I mean I'd
rather not see it nowadays it has been
100% confirmed that they related exactly
right yes this scene was brought to you
by Ben and Dave do you think they could
do this to possibly impregnate Danny oh
god I hope not
I know I don't but oh no don't don't do
that
oh don't do that that that's been a very
big thing that's been talked about ever
since this scene has been brought up
that oh my god is John going to get
Danny pregnant in the one of the very
last scenes is the kid being born Oh God
hmm yeah you know I wouldn't we're just
gonna with no words we're gonna move to
ask this no no no we're not doing this
one no no no oh God let's move on then
of men on that alright so very last
scene there's one more scene the wall
falls at the end of the episode the
night King attacks the wall was zombie
Viserion is able to knock it down I mean
you know it's a pretty dope cliffhanger
I have no problem with that scene
whatsoever yeah if the night king knocks
down the wall with the zombie dragon the
internet is going to effing explode yes
100% and it would be totally justified
we've been waiting since season 1 to see
that wall fall down we thought it might
fall in season 5 after hard fall yeah at
the run home thought it might fall in
the season 6
after hold the door and that wall stood
and so now damn it no we need to see the
wall fall and so if it does that at the
end of season 7 I will be happy I will
have absolutely nothing to complain
about and that episode for me will
probably get an automatic 10 out of 10
just for that scene alone if they don't
destroy everything else in the episodes
right I've always been kind of picturing
that scene at the very end of the
episode you see the wall fall and right
as the dust settles you see the lower
commander looking on the other side of
the wall that's now collapsed and as he
looks out to the distance his eyes are
wide like 250 some pieces and you see
the night king and his army just
stepping over the rubble walking into
Castle black and then it fades the black
that would be sick yeah that would be
beyond ridiculous I mean oh man the
tension would be through the roof yeah
man man oh man well yeah I have
absolutely no problem with that
and that's what I want to see and yeah
so guys make sure you do it right will
you do it was there something else you
said you wanted to touch on real quick
yeah so okay so let's talk about jaws
bear
for a quick closer how many times have
we heard about the tawny at harrenhal
and hearing about Rhaegar and Lyanna you
know and you know Rhaegar absconded with
Liana and raped her and also the stuff
now we know obviously that Rhaegar did
not rape her and he probably did not
kidnap her but we you know when it comes
to the whole plot week thing remember
one of the big things that a lot of
people talked about was was that one
that one musician was talking about that
he might be playing Rhaegar and Game of
Thrones or something
he had a blond blond haired guy right if
you notice in the plot week we got
absolutely nothing about Rhaegar
whatsoever nope not a single sentence
you know so that to me is pretty
interesting so I'm wondering you know
what happened with Rhaegar will we get
to see Rhaegar Targaryen increase in
seven I mean because I'll be honest with
you I think that that they don't do some
version of the Tony at Harrenhal and how
Rhaegar and Lyanna got together it will
be an absolute travesty now if they
happen to be saving it for season eight
it is what it is but I think that after
the setup with brand you know
discovering what happened at the tower
joy in season six
I think the follow up the right thing to
do for us the season seven is to give us
the twenty Harrenhal I agree I think if
they do it they do need to do that in
season seven
yeah because season eight will just be
too far away and plus you're already
talking about shorting shortening the
season to six episodes so yeah we need
to Tony Aaron hall a little earlier oh
and and then another thing you know who
else has been missing from this entire
plot week whose
that Varys that's true what the hell is
he doing for the entire season yeah
we've heard absolutely nothing about
Varys I've been asked that question
probably 500 times what is Varys doing
there's no photos of him there's no
reports of him what the hell is this guy
doing for the whole season right and I
mean like think about it I mean look at
me and you know towards the middle last
season we got the whole thing with him
and kinvaras var telling him oh I know
what you heard and the fire and you know
who that uh that that wizard spoke to
and all that and do you want to know
what happened and what was said looks
like uh yeah yeah we got we got to find
that out
yeah you can't you leave a thread like
that dangling and think people are going
to totally forget about it because that
was one of Eris's defining moments in
his life I mean he talked about how you
know after he built up his fly Network
how he tracked that magician down just
so he could bring the King's Landing and
torture him
so how crazy is that keeping them in
that Auckland yes well now that we know
that you know there's other people out
there who know what it is that he went
through but you can't just leave that
dangling as a dangling thread and not
answer that so yeah we need to find out
what the deal is with Varys and I just
find it absolutely uh absolutely
shocking that with this whole particular
plot week situation that we heard
absolutely nothing about there I got two
questions on that for you Wilkin vara
travel with Danny to Westeros and do you
think Varys may try to kill her do you
everything
Varis in the book and show are very
similar but at the same point show varus
would never kill anyone you don't think
so
no show here is not habit in them yes so
varus does not have an eminence in him
to kill anyone not even to order an
execution um so what I mean but he's
gotta have a reason to order for kin
whare to be killed right well I mean do
you think he could just be like he
doesn't want to get that that
information to get out whatever the hell
actually all went down with that do you
think cuz he's definitely scared by what
she said to him do you think it could
come to a point to where he's like I
gotta shut this [ __ ] up it's possible
but god damn it we need to learn true
first yeah I agree I definitely want to
find out yeah man I've known absolute
killer killed well again I would you
know what I would rather him that killed
Kim Guara Bank is a yeah Kim Bauer was
rockin that dress oh my god did you see
that uh she was she was definitely
talked Evie yeah you know she invited
everyone to watch The Cleveland Show and
it was definitely getting vibrating oh
my god absolutely and that that's the
first time we've ever seen Varys like
petrified like that right because you
know that was the first thing because
remember Varys knows all and for him to
have that one very traumatic moment in
his life where not only was he powerless
to stop any yeah yeah it stopped it from
happening
but for him to not know what was said
and for someone else to roll up on him
like yeah I know I know everything about
this situation one of the most defining
moments of your life I know what it
truly means and you don't that would be
terrifying yeah
so yeah man damn but we have a hurricane
thing about Kim Barra whatsoever either
so you know they answer your first
question I don't I don't think that she
went with Daenerys to Westeros
there was a photo that came out months
ago when they first started filming on
Dragonstone and off in the distance you
can't see someone wearing all red but
you can't tell exactly who it is but it
definitely looks like the red
priestesses like red dress or whatever
that is hmm okay I mean look you know
what if she's there
cool excellent we we need that in our
life it's a very important thing some
people speculated that it maybe
Melisandre and and you know what that is
another character that we've heard
absolutely nothing about we've heard
zero about Melisandre ya know leaked
photos or anything nothing I mean I
think people got so hyped on Gendry
coming back that it was like yes what
all the people were missing right and
Melisandre she still has a big role to
play I think right so I mean then you
know I've heard people speculate that
she would go north of the wall but no
she traveled south so but oh you know
what I heard a version of the Platte
League
I forgot exactly where I heard it but I
heard a version of the Platte League
that says that Arya is going to kill
Melisandre yeah I definitely I think
they are going to meet up as arias
heading north and she's heading south I
do think we will get that you know that
part but I don't know if she's going to
kill her
Arya could be wearing a different face
Melisandre could have her necklace off
and she's traveling as the old woman
like you know I'm not too sure but I do
think those two will meet again yeah I
mean that is only to be interesting but
yeah I'm really
I hope that they do not kill off
Melisandre just yet
what do you think her end game is oh
that is hmm I've heard Tony Teflon say
that she is going to end up being the
night Queen what do you think about that
I mean what have you talking about the
books yeah I could definitely see that
happening as far as the show is
concerned I am I am not exactly sure
what the end game this pulse could be
yeah it's kind of hard to put my finger
on what she's gonna do man but I know
she's going to come back into the story
and it's got to be something big to
indeed you know we really need
Melisandre loud so yeah you know you
guys need to need to go ahead and make
that happen and everybody listen in
comment below and tell us what you think
mellow songs was then game going to be
what do you think we're going to see
with her in season 7 and season 8 like
when we see her again what do you think
she's going to be up to is she going to
try to infiltrate back into the North
even though John ordered her away it's
already going to kill her is she going
to try to go with Danny what do you
think she's going to do definitely
comment below and I want to see what you
guys have to say about Melisandre now
are there any other characters that were
missing um there's one last scene in
this plot leaked if you want to talk
about it the dragon pit scene oh yeah
that's right well how do we how did we
miss that one they put it at the very
bottom of this website and it says
unsure of chronology so it's hard to say
but I'll read it real quick it says
later in this season there will be a
scene at a dragon pit with almost the
entire cast of the show there will be a
parlay between Cersei and Dany allowing
them all to meet at said dragon pit John
brings the white he captured in order to
show all the Lords of the danger facing
Westeros Cersei orders the mountain to
kill the white witch she cannot even
after cutting it
[ __ ] John explains only dragonglass can
kill these zombies Cersei responds that
she will certainly send help to John but
later in private she tells Jaime she was
lying she explains she welcomes the
coming of the zombie horde so they can
take out her enemies
Jaime is disgusted by this and leaves
her to ride north ok well here is thing
so dragonglass does not kill a white
that's first and foremost
dragonglass does not kill whites it
kills white walkers yeah I'm not sure
why John would say that I've questioned
that many times yeah so you know that's
already one thing not a Jaime and Cersei
thing I could see that going down in
terms of her saying hey you know what
yeah I want I want them all to die
anyway so [ __ ] it it doesn't matter um
yeah yeah she's kind of on that [ __ ] the
world burn it to the ground type [ __ ]
anyway so yeah I agree she might just
say [ __ ] them let them take out the
north yeah you know hashtag burn them
all yup exactly right yeah so I could
definitely see that boy dabbing in and
we know well I mean according to all the
reports and [ __ ] that I've seen there is
a dragon pit that they acquired to fill
meant for this next season and a report
came out that had a big list of the
characters that would be there and there
was some interesting characters if that
list is accurate we will see both of the
Clegane brothers there we're going to
see Theon and you're on there we're
going to see Jon and Jamie they're like
there's going to be a lot of enemies
there at this dragon pit scene so it's
going to be crazy as hell to see yeah
it's going to be yeah think it was like
18 characters and they were all pretty
big characters yeah I met a little worse
man I'm curious like if there's an
actual parlay scene like I wonder the
tension is going to be you're going to
be able to cut that tension with a knife
man with having both the claw games
there and we know you're on wants to
kill fee on Plus Cersei and Dany and
then you know Jon has a problem with
Jaime with any of the Lannisters really
just don't be a slow song though because
they want songs are dead it's going to
be very interesting to see yeah indeed
and you know um I can't wait to see what
they do with the whole dragon pit scene
you know and also another thing that is
going to be very interesting for season
7 I mean even though this is going to be
kind of far away but one thing is going
to be very interesting is the histories
and lore that they pack with the season
7 blu-rays that is true that is true
what do you think they're going to
include in that um I mean I think
they're gonna have to include
some more stuff about you know just the
the working of Dragons and maybe if it
is true about the maesters killing off
dragons maybe it might actually show how
the maesters did it you know yeah
there's a lot of stuff out there that
you know we're going to need to be able
to learn about yeah this is going to be
a dragon heavy season because they
attack Jaime
the dragon apparently gets killed and
raised there's the dragon pit you know
there's a lot of dragon [ __ ] going on in
this season right so yeah it's going to
be very interesting to see um you know
what's going to happen in terms of how
they use the Dragons and I mean how much
of them they have because you know we
also know that the CGI for the Dragons
is very expensive but they shortened the
season and I think they still have the
same
budget that means they have an extra 30
million dollars to spend on dragons
absolutely so 30 million dollars I want
to see some more goddamn dragons and
don't kill off Nymeria yeah we're gonna
have to see a lot more White Walkers and
Knight King - and whites yeah and that's
kind of man that is going to be crazy I
mean them but Plus also they're gonna
have what is it a white polar bear and
uh you know a nice spider and turn
Andres Ariane into a white dragon mean
yeah you know it's going to cost a lot
of money
I hope they spend it on that I'd love to
see that [ __ ] man I definitely want to
see you know I know some people have
issue with the ice dragon but to see one
of Danny's dragons have to fight the ice
dragon goddamn that'd be incredible yeah
yeah incredible indeed yeah I mean it
will like it or not man if that does
present itself on screen no one's going
to complain I don't think nah not me
definitely not me not on me either man
but what do you think overall dawn after
we just went through all that how much
so that do you think we'll we'll
actually see
um so percentage-wise I'm gonna say
about eighty-five percent you know I
hate to agree with you because I do want
to be surprised but you might be right
man when I first started talking about
this plot leaked I was under the
impression that it was going to be fake
but when more and more photos and
reports kept coming out to back it up
it's getting harder and harder to deny
yeah and that's the thing about it you
know look you know so far when it comes
to this whole thing about reporting on
plot leaks and breaking it all down you
are the king when it comes to that man
you know so much respect to you
and gratitude to you for you know
jumping into this whole thing and you
know kind of kind of showing people you
know a great time and just being able to
say you know what this is a place where
we can come and we want to get the
latest updates you know it's right here
so my hats off to you sir I appreciate
Dom Willy coming from you that's the
highest praise like I've told you off
air you were one of the first channels I
came across I watched a shitload of your
live streams it always looked like so
much fun that was one of the main
reasons I started doing this in which
you could see in old comments on your
old videos hey man I just created a
channel because I want to join the panel
discussion with you guys so to finally
have that opportunity to do it I'm very
happy and I hope that we do a lot more
of these in the future yeah you know and
thank you again for having me on your
channel and also you know thank you for
the shout-out you gave me earlier in one
of your videos
tomorrow gave me a nice little influx of
subscribers so if any of you who have
subscribed to me recently who come to
watch this video thank you and it's
anyone who's going to watch this video
later on you know thank you
in advance and hopefully you'll come and
check out my channel as well absolutely
definitely go subscribe to a Dawn of Ice
and Fire
he has a shitload of content over there
guys he has broken down almost
everything that you guys can think of
he's been making videos for a very long
time there's hours and hour I mean if
you add up all the hours of recording
time you have it's days and days and
weeks of content so when you get bored
here go over there and you have endless
hours of content and dawn breaks down
everything the books in the show very
well so go subscribe to his channel he's
got some new stuff he's been working on
that's going to be coming out in a few
future hopefully he can have meal in his
channel and I'll be over there we'll do
some stuff together and definitely when
season seven comes back on I plan on
doing a lot of live streams so
definitely stay tuned for that and I
appreciate you guys for spending the
time with us I know this was a very long
video but hopefully you guys enjoyed it
we broke down as much stuff as we could
and I thank you for that and Dawn before
you go is there anything you'd like to
say before you sign off sir uh you know
again just thank you for having me you
know if you're not subscribed to the
channel please make sure to go do that
drop a like on this video drop a like on
all these videos and also if you want to
catch me any other places look out for
the hikes watch channel you know we do
monthly discussions about a different
chapter on the books so if you happen to
be into the books lul and I just want to
listen to a nice reread where we go and
break down the chapters and have a nice
little panel discussion make sure to
check me out over there too and yeah you
know we'll definitely be doing some more
these collaborations in the future but
uh you know my normal sign offs for all
my videos is great comment subscribe
share tell your friends come back for
more and that has been my times I'm
releasing valid dohaeris Thank You Don
really I'm very happy to have you on and
I will see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]
you